boatos pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
vídeo e os traduz de que eu pareço um dj
vai pessoal é o estrago de que um vídeo
band frente eu andava por aí na internet
e vi umas animações nos vídeos fazem sem
fred e ele teve a idéia e adiyiah que o
estilo comigo estando moneo teve então a
ideia de existir essas animações com
vocês aqui em vídeo reagir ao vivo com
vocês enquanto eu e você estamos a virar
animação ao mesmo tempo isso é muito
forte aqui no youtube o pessoal
normalmente agora eu também já fez
vídeos deste ano em geral estrelas
painéis é fredes de não sair dessa sem
fazer esse tipo de vídeo porque o
investidor vende sozinho e dirige
sozinho e azul em vídeo e vocês podem
ver comigo e comentário que chegaram
também acho que você não muito off mesmo
por isso nenhuma isso vocês gostam desta
ideia de continuar com este vídeo é
reagir outros vídeos não sei
tô doido gravar sim da vontade então a
gente já fala não estamos tão perto o
filme envolve bacaxá
ela não disse que me amava fila mas o
entrave está na descrição por isso agora
deixem no zero e vamos começar a ver
isso ao mesmo tempo vou fazer a contagem
porque estão prontos 321 kleybanova o
vídeo é pequeno vídeo de 14 minutos só
que estamos num sítio com uma cadeira de
rodas já andaram doente porque o ok nós
foi um gesto os 33 já apareceu nas rocky
eu não sei se inspire tem dito que quer
ou não porque ainda não houve nenhuma
expectativa porque assim o próximo caiu
us 30 por seu eu vou apanhar não é
o gum é a minha cara de não faz mal o
boi não assine
acho que eu devo no cu olhando sanyo uma
produção do ar com nena eu vou deixar os
links todos na descrição quem fez a
animação do canal eu vou deixar tudo por
espaço privado pois é ótimo ver estas
animações
eu gosto do sr aqui estamos dispostos
também estamos na pizzaria da família e
fred três na época os princ trepp
originalmente por seu
no fluminense fred trecho estão em gum
caiu ainda porque ou será que houve
alguma coisa
uma televisão estragada é sinal do
demônio que vai acontecer agora explicou
polícia
eu comecei a escolha pensaria isso vai
dar orgulho - eu não sei mas eu acho que
o assunto diz morrer agora estão a
investigar não é não vai correr nisso
não vai correr nada vai nos separar
entregue já estava lá espreitar a cair
afirma ter a firma tem o caraças
afirmativo caraças e andaraí em andaraí
ó exatamente está atrás da porta o que é
que o cabeça de empresas
eu não sei se as pessoas gostarem a lei
não valeu ou não vai é o miro é não se
você não fazer isso você te entrevistar
dentro daquela porta né mesmo cabeça
o o ol entregue país estar agora estou
sentindo champions que era para elas e
cueca pessoal estou inteiro
ok então as regras não correr não borrar
as regras alteram ou eles deram de caras
com os tempo agora agora é agora um
ambiente está tenso até agora tá tenso
que a caixa está entregue a uma pessoa
não é irmão do som da curva então a
porta
acho que o humor com tiros à série a de
tentar matar a esposa em trânsito
precisa de lança chamas e e e se matar
não é a sério a série é uma tolice com
um soco
sério
a vontade de chorar
os polícias todos os olhos a melhor
chamar os médicos uma cabeça que fala é
agora um pouco no japão o nikkei ainda
não conhece seu foco em reunião com ele
aqui numa eu não tinha sistema
eletrônico deve ser um fã assim o
pessoal não percebi porque é que a
escolha por se agora no fim do vídeo mas
vamos ficar por aqui com o espírito
espero que vocês tenham gostado eu adoro
ver esse tipo de coisa e principalmente
se você estiver em assistir comigo então
ainda melhor como é que vocês acharam
que querem que eu continue a fazer este
tipo filho já dirigir não só animações
páginas entregues mas outro tipo de
coisa que seja engraçado assim deixa eu
gosto é que o favorito não esqueçam tudo
não estão na descrição por isso passei
por lá
apoiem os canais fazem estas animações e
sério isso deve dar trabalho para
caraças animar este tipo de coisa porém
mesmo esses canais a sério e
e é isso vamos ficar porque se quebrou e
até a próxima
ae